[Music]
action
whatever we want whatever we want
it's gonna be not whatever we want it's
gonna be
narcissists oh cool what we're talking
about
i like them do you guys like like it
when it's like
um like um damn it i can't think of an
example
yes like what oh like a bunch of
consonants put together yeah those are
fun
skittles texts she's saying like when
it's like a like narcissists
or disks oh i see but but but what if
you had a kid that just had a lisp
and then they just always talked like
that well it wouldn't be like
it'd be like oh it's not the same yeah
but narcissist i don't know
yeah well how about how about us how
about a snake
anyway anyway okay never mind let's talk
about narcissism all right are we all
stoned did i not get the memo
we don't don't you guys are buzzed
we you did serve us your buzz
the only same people here is bart and
joe or sober people is departing
well but they're naturally drunk yeah
exactly meeting us we're catching up to
them
anyway i'm trying to talk to you guys
about this new study that
suggests suggests you're right
it's a gift um that
narcissists think that they don't make
mistakes so
therefore they do not learn from their
mistakes because they don't even think
that they're even making any
hmm yeah mistakes if you're wondering
what is a narcissist it is a way of
describing someone with excessive
interest or
admiration for themselves and unlike
most people
they do not engage in something known as
should
counter factual thinking which is where
a person
analyzes their past actions to see what
they should have done differently
narcissists don't even think about that
they're like what are you talking about
like
i'm perfectly fine like i did not make a
mistake that
went exactly the way it should have been
because i'm perfect
yeah so a lot of youtubers a lot of
youtubers yes this is what makes me
think that i'm not
a narcissist for anybody who ever called
me a narcissist why because you
i think i do think very highly of myself
and that like i'm like the [ __ ] at
things
you are i'm i'm thank you yeah but i
also am very like critical of myself and
like ah maybe i i'm or i should have
done this or i could have done that
differently
or you know maybe i shouldn't ate the
booty like that maybe i should have
maybe i should have went
counterclockwise instead of clockwise
yeah yeah yeah if you like your own
pictures or your narcissist
yeah on instagram yeah i do see that
sometimes and i'm like you know you can
see here
like we can we can all see that a
narcissist is like oh good it says i
like it
i don't know because sometimes like i
get self-conscious you know when you're
scrolling you're just hitting stuff
right
and then like you like you're like
looking at your old picture and you you
accidentally tap it
and then you'd like you oh no i want
people to see that i like my own picture
that's weird i've never done i do that
i do i do that a lot sometimes i'll be
looking at like from photos from like
five years ago
yeah i'm like oh look how cute isaac was
so small and i'd be like look casey i'm
like oh [ __ ] i liked it
yeah and you know in that moment like
[ __ ] 50 profiles were refreshing
their
their their their pages narcissist
they like their own photos they don't
have that anymore that feature where you
see what other people are doing
they don't have that anymore but you
think 50 whole people are looking at
your post five years ago with a
narcissist
damn i'm a narcissist the activity fee
okay so tim's not a narcissist i guess
he just passed the test tiff why are you
not a narcissist give us a counter
factual about yourself go
oh because i constantly self-edit and i
take other people's criticism of myself
and i apply them to myself because i'm
like you're right i'm not perfect let me
[ __ ] change myself not a narcissist
check
joe there are different levels of
narcissism that everyone
holds and everyone who think that they
don't have these traits of them
are showing characteristics of
narcissism and damn
you just prove that to why i am a
narcissist and he also made himself a
little bit of a narcissist because he
didn't say any of his faults
i think we all are we all have a little
bit at least i think so
this book called laws of human nature he
uh uh the the author i forgot his name
but he's [ __ ] dope oh his name is mr
green robert green that's what it is
and then he he basically has like a
family member
of different types of narcissists so
in our mind we have this archetype of
what what a narcissist is it's one
person that can never take criticism
it's this
worst form of narcissism right but
in the book there's like victim
differences yeah there's victim on ours
who's
always pretending to be self-conscious
but in reality
it's more about it's more about hey hey
look at me because
look at my problems these are my
problems you see how i self reflect
and then it's almost like look at my
attention this is my attention think i'm
one of those
that's a youtuber narcissist literally
i'm doing it well
everybody who's on youtube to an extent
is a narcissist
to think that people would actually
enjoy you putting a camera on your face
and there's healthy narcissism too
because there's a story of a person
who was a captain that uh took his team
out to the arctic
right so um he believed that
in order for them to survive yet you
have to have this narcissistic trait
that you cannot
get your your your whole uh uh shipmates
to die
you are super human you can motivate
them so you use this narcissism
in a positive light to to to be like i
could be the one that saves everybody
here
and then you use that energy to like to
to keeping people alive because if you
think about it right like
you have this hero effect like let's say
you're a firefighter you're doing
something for people but
that idea that you are special enough to
run into that place with the burning
building
and grab people out risk your own life
and come out alive
it is a form of narcissism who you're
just confident why you got to put an
ugly word on it
it becomes ugly because of how we've
tainted it
and then there's the there's an extreme
harmful side of it so then if you look
at this list it's pretty interesting
so then is there anyone who is just
absolutely
zero percent narcissistic no this sounds
like
every single human being has some sort
of narcissism i think so because
narcissism is
tied to egoism unless you're enlightened
then you're not we're talking about an
extreme
form when you think of the word
narcissist right you're thinking about
someone who's stubborn
crazy they don't listen to anything
american psycho narcissist
yeah but there's also people who have
this like
ability to think they're way better like
michael jordan i'm way
better than all these other [ __ ] when
it comes to this game and i'll practice
ten times better than everybody and get
better
that is a narcissistic self uh what are
you calling
very self-absorbed yeah like i'm better
than you right but then he's right but
it's a healthy way of
proving them right but it becomes right
it's kind of like how celebrities and
all these people
show traits of crazy narcissism but it
pushes them
to achieving so much right so i don't
know if
i think that the basic layman's term or
like how we view it
we're seeing it one-dimensional we're
seeing the ugliest traits and we're
seeing somebody
with these like despicable like like
characteristics we see the brand in the
media like
like it's the the american psycho thing
like we just go that's a narcissist
instead of seeing all the minutia right
right like for example people that might
be
um labeled a psychopath or or
anti-social or whatever right like
like there are like like that guy in
free dive
like what's this free solo free solo
there are extreme sports
people who have all the characteristics
of maybe a serial killer or whatever but
they didn't
choose to kill a lot of people they just
chose to
flip on a motorcycle 10 20 times you
know and do some scary [ __ ] but he's
channeled
that superpower into something healthy
true that makes sense so so there's
nuance to it there's a lot on there
nothing's black and white controlling
that energy into good rather than into
bad
yeah i see yeah all right well back to
the or did you have to do this no i mean
i was just gonna say
i mean that thought process could be
taken for any type of energy though then
right
that's why that word is supposed to be
neutral but because the way we've been
branded
it seems like it only is one way but
it's supposed to be just a neutral word
and you experience different spectrums
of it yeah i agree
it should be approached as a spectrum i
don't know if it is
there's a negative connotation to it you
know well for this particular
article it doesn't they're not
approaching it as a spectrum they're
saying like narcissists are this way
normal people are this way
so the university said the fact that
they're not able to look back on their
past actions and then try to correct
them they're saying narcissists do this
way
more that they don't because they think
they're better than
others they don't take advice from other
people they don't trust other people's
opinions
so you can flat out ask what should you
have done differently
and it might be nothing it turned out it
was good
it was fine i had i didn't have to do
anything wrong so that's just something
that they're
looking into that they're saying because
of the fact that narcissists
textbook narcissists do not
think that they make any mistakes
therefore they do not learn from their
mistakes
i definitely do think i'm better than
other people
do you every single person you encounter
you're like your advice is stupid i'm
not gonna listen to you wait
here's here's what kind of helped me be
at at peace with with life right
because like you know just being on the
internet you think like god people are
so stupid right like how is
every comment on youtube and on twitter
so stupid right everyone's so dumb
you're like i love you tim you're stupid
i got those but then i realized oh wait
it's not that they're stupid
it's that i'm better and then once you
realize that you are a superior human
beautiful and
everybody's just not on your level you
don't get angry anymore you feel sorry
for them
it's a coping mechanism you're like oh
man these people aren't dumb
i'm just better it sucks that they're
not on my level
a healthy way to approach that that
thought process
is to be more empathetic to people
they just don't have the same sort of
you're stupid because you didn't go to
school
you're just not that smart and uh that's
really nice
[Music]
and that's the thing it's not even about
education it's about the common sense
it's about it's just different we're not
just that but like just their their
environment
where they live like what they've lived
through what kind of education or yeah
education that they've had or experience
life experiences that they're like oh
you just haven't had this life
experience that's why we always think at
least for me
i always think like when i see a really
really out there comment where i'm like
that makes no sense
i always tell myself like well they're
probably like 12 years old they just
don't even have
life experience giving marriage advice
yeah like that happens all the time but
once you understand
people though because i think that
people can only be truly good at two
things
so when i see people i see a smorgasbord
of things
and maybe i respect them for two of them
but that that means that anyone can be
respected for different things i think
so i don't i don't necessarily look at
like oh i'm better
than you the whole you maybe i'm better
than you at something but you're
probably
much better than me at something like
you can't expect a fish to fly kind of
thing yeah exactly
so i just see people as like uh their
qualities almost instead of
like this grand picture of i'm better
than yeah i try to look at
people to see what their reality is
because the thing is
we all think we're sharing the same
reality but it's not true
yeah like like everyone's experience is
based off of their
personal history with their family their
environment and all that right so like
i'm i'm always asking the question when
they're reacting to me
are they reacting to themselves because
they're just playing a
story in their own minds i don't know if
i'm making any sense no no don't don't
but don't doesn't everybody do that
don't you get mad at people who do the
things that you used to do
yeah you [ __ ] pissed about it yeah so
like same [ __ ] that's what really
relieved everything is like okay so who
in here
is actually like out of like they see
the matrix like who
is seeing the matrix for what it is and
who's living
still in the matrix and then based off
of how they respond
and what they're talking about and when
they talk about like this happen between
me and my friend or my family or
whatever i'm
i can gauge now at what point of their
cognitive like realization they're in so
like what point are they in
where they're like uh if they're if like
like a textbook narcissist right
they're in their mind as a hero nothing
has been wrong they're in this video
game like they're they they just
the world is against them and they're
just trying to win and then i'm like
dude that's an interesting world to be
in
because that's why a lot of narcissists
can
make it because they don't feel the pain
of
losing they just don't lose they just
keep going and i'm like that's
interesting another person might see a
whole entire different experience and be
constantly like losing like if they're
super depressed or whatever and they're
always looking and they're self-critical
and i'm like
we're all sharing the same world
together how is it that one person's in
a different game than me because
if narcissism is a spectrum then that
that's the spectrum it's like
i'm a god or i'm nothing yeah yeah
right the guy that's that feels they're
nothing is just as narcissistic as a
person everyone's about me
me me yeah yeah it's still bad yeah like
both ends of a spectrum are yeah
the best that's why looking around for
the things that make you awesome
can be just as destructive as looking
around for all the reasons why you suck
i think that most people are living life
going me
me me me me me all day [ __ ] long
that's the ego that's true
if you have a social media account
you're a narcissist
that's a good talk right did you think
you talked better than all of us
[Music]
[Music]
you